craig newmark is the craig of craigslist
he founded the website
in 1995 and he's worth about 1 billion
and that's a very conservative estimate
of his net worth
it's based on an estimated minimum 42
stake in craigslist as well as the
hundreds of millions of profits that
he's gotten through the website
in the last two decades he's a unique
character i mean he's unlike any other
billionaire that i've ever interviewed
for one he makes himself very accessible
and
you know he still lives in the same
house in san francisco
in a very quiet neighborhood in coal
valley he's just like a really normal
person
i think a lot of reporters here in the
newsroom started seeing
all these gifts that craig was giving to
journalism to cyber security to election
integrity
craig read this book called the handbook
of russian information warfare
it was published by nato defense
college's research division
and it was this handbook that
essentially told the reader
what the russians were doing to
essentially
polarize different groups in the country
with the goal of division
chaos and government destabilization
and so given all these goals that
these foreign adversaries had craig
thought that
really giving to journalism cyber
security and election integrity was the
best way to fight against that
so i emailed craig and asked if he'd be
open to speaking with me about
his charity and he said yes
they're all parts of the same thing
having to do with defending our country
against attack by our foreign
adversaries
and their domestic allies that means
protecting the election
which is the major ballot space this
year and
that includes countering harassment
especially directed against journalists
and it
also involves trying to tell people of
media
to avoid amplifying this information
but the idea is to try to stop
bad actors from attacking our election
he's most worried about foreign
adversaries uh having control of our
government
but he also said that he was worried
about the domestic allies the foreign
adversaries
there are parties in the u.s are trying
to destabilize the country
when a country is destabilized it
provides opportunities for
the unscrupulous to make a lot of money
and
gain power that's what i'm worried about
and if you look at his twitter feed you
know the stories that he's been sharing
and retweeting
they're all about the election and
they're all about pointing out
you know the lies that trump has been
saying out of media
[Music]
as a journalist there's always a danger
in having a wealthy benefactor
um be your sole source of revenue right
you have jeff bezos owning the
washington post
mark benioff owns time magazine
shouldn't we
come up with you know a more
self-sustaining model so that we're not
beholden to these wealthy benefactors
right
but at the same time i think craig is
being thoughtful
with how he's giving back to journalism
he's giving back to schools
he's funding existing newsrooms like
propublica
he's got to focus on non-profit
newsrooms and
it'll be interesting to see how craig
strategizes his giving in the coming
years
i mean 2020 is going to be a pretty
decisive year for craig
it's going to tell him whether all this
money that he's given
has been a good investment or if it's
gone to waste
depending on what happens in november
that's definitely going to affect how
craig gives
but we'll just have to wait and watch
[Music]
you